il y à là toutes les couleurs tous les
étendards toutes les tendances
il y à des représentants de toutes les
corporations tous les métiers mais dans
le fond ils ne sont qu'un là c'est quand
même un événement notre république parce
que c'est aussi permettre d'avoir une
partie de la population qu'ils soient
autonomes dans ses comportements et
qu'ils soient pas sous le diktat d'un
finances esaïe ne supporte pas ce
qu'elles veulent faire disparaître les
statuts ou parce que ça nous donne une
indépendance qu'il est plus difficile
d'avoir lorsqu'on est soumis aux patrons
santé éducation transport énergie emploi
culture
la liste est longue au moins autant que
le cortège bien sûr il y à des salaires
le point d'indicé les retraites mais au
coeur des revendications un seul mot
d'ordre sauver le service public la
santé l'éducation de dakar à côté comme
ça pouvait arriver de ce site anglo
saxon des riches pour à peu près tous
les pouvoirs que les privilèges et puis
les pauvres qui vont galérer dans le
corps a du mal à boucler leurs fins de
mois
colin baisser la société qui nous attend
c'est ce qu'ils nous proposent après
faut qu'on soit capable de se mobiliser
on encore pas assez nombreux
[Musique]
après ce sera notre génération c'est la
troisième fois sous l'ère macule que les
fonctionnaires convergent vers la
préfecture et certainement pas la
dernière
la réforme annoncée pour 2019 et les
cent vingt mille suppressions de postes
programmées pour 2022 continueront
d'alimenter le brasier